allez on va accueillir la rédac Sacha
elle base
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un espèce de mini Jean-Pierre Foucault
de Jean-Pierre Foucault
[Applaudissements]
tu es magnifique
ou si vous êtes très beau aujourd'hui et
si vous pouvez me passer la chemise
quand vous en voulez plus elle est très
très belle à toucher c'est incroyable
c'est magnifique
il a le droit à une feuille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
terreau
de parfum
toi
qui est la moyenne d'âge des
chroniqueurs de l'équipe de TPMP 75 75
ans oui à vue d'œil c'est ce qu'on
pourrait se dire sauf que parfois il
suffit d'un petit jeu de mots ou de
trois lettres pour que la moyenne d'âge
tombe à 6 ans et demi
sans le son c'est mieux je pense on a
pas de son les gars
et oui donc notre invité remet une pièce
dans la machine en pour l'instant c'est
le fameux trois lettres directement
au lieu de confier l'article alors
journaliste
et quand c'est trois lettres sont
prononcées par Nicolas perlikov alors là
on a perdu tout le monde moi je trouve
que ça chatte GPT révolutionnaire
effectivement parce que
vous êtes con
[Applaudissements]
c'est impossible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de la meuf dans la classe qui veut pas
rentrer dans le Nord
moi j'ai envie d'apprendre
c'est bon hein
[Rires]
j'ai pas envie d'avoir votre bac moi
j'ai envie de l'avoir
[Rires]
on continue avec Bernard Montiel qui a
été légèrement troublé par nos invités
[Musique]
[Rires]
cette semaine il a été très très troublé
Bernard
et des éléments
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
incroyable on passe à Benjamin Castaldi
numéro 1 sur les régimes et les blagues
en loups 13 ans 8 enfants tu te doutes
bien enfin tu vois après 8 post-partum
enfin tu vois on est hyper contente
[Rires]
calme-toi
c'est que l'échec rend agressifs
de quoi
non c'est pas un échec est-ce qu'elle
était bonne mais en fait tu l'as mal
placé c'est vraiment c'est ma vie
toujours
le sens du rythme ça va toi
non mais ça va en ce moment ça va partir
si non ça va
[Rires]
dans la bouche
normal
rappelez-vous la semaine dernière il a
eu des propos très durs envers les chats
vous savez tout ce qui est moitié
que cette séquence a donné une petite
idée à Raymond pendant la pub regardez
moi si j'ai un rendez-vous si j'ai un
rendez-vous 20 minutes après qu'on ne
retape pas mon train qu'on coupe le chat
en deux il a dit ça
[Applaudissements]
non Raymond c'est pas notre style
refaire un dossier le lendemain c'est
mal connaître les conducteurs de Baba la
question que vous pose à 20h12 en direct
Benjamin Castaldi est-il allé trop loin
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et justement en parlant de cette
histoire de chat
en parlant de cette histoire de chat
vous avez lancé un avis de recherche
Cyril car Benjamin Castaldi a perdu
quelque chose de très important durant
ce débat est-ce que vous pouvez répéter
Gilles devant Grisière et David c'est ce
qu'a dit Benjamin Castillet
ne commence pas à perdre je change pas
d'avis je différencie le drame qu'on
vécu les propriétaires du chat ça y est
il a perdu ses
meilleurs
un train d'abord
une fois
et en plus et je vais vous dire la
vérité
soit quelqu'un de sécurité pour le chat
mais je suis désolé on retarde pas faire
du CX on compris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est descendu ça fait chute
pas un train qu'est-ce qu'il y a comment
je veux que je me concentre avec un
quelqu'un qui gesticule en face de moi
tout le temps la crédit grimace
mais toi tu commences à me gonfler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
juste un conseil qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu
es sûr que parce que j'ai l'impression
que tu es sérieuse
je te parle en ami et j'ai l'impression
que ça se fait zozoter de ouf
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
comment tu vas
attention mais à quoi fais attention
une autre émission dans ces tabou un
gars qui se lève
fais attention fais attention fais
attention
attention à quoi ben moi attention à toi
aussi toi attention
[Rires]
Castaldi et c'est le seul gars quand il
vient mettre un coup de pression frère
tu l'attends au moins 10 minutes
et après il vérifie si c'est la bonne
personne excusez-moi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
de plus en plus loin
il est mort de rire mais il
répond est mort de rire mais il le sera
moins dans quelques secondes je sais de
quoi tu veux
que vous parliez du meilleur de Raymond
pour Sophie cost mais figurez-vous que
lui en ce moment il était EF top très en
folie
il y a quelques jours on recevait
Charlie Bousquet vous rappelle de Caméra
Café très jolie et à mon avis il avait
peut-être envie de lui proposer une
petite capsule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je suis en ligne je peux te parler
2 minutes
mais je sais pas si c'est forcément une
bonne idée de le laisser faire
pas du tout pas du tout viens boire 2
secondes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
me faire un piège deux personnes venant
de comédie vous allez pas me piéger
parce que vous avez sûrement et tu mets
pas la suite la suite c'est que je les
ai pas cru une seconde ils ont travaillé
les deux à comédie pas une seconde
j'espère quand même du front je trouve
déjà chopé une meuf que tu as dragué ici
en 7 ans ou pas non mais jamais sérieux
il est marié vraiment vraiment
rigoler mais derrière il rentre dans son
camion et je peux te dire que c'est
parce qu'il peut pas parce qu'il a pas
envie mais non il est pas là il était il
est il est maquillé
ça tourne alors il lui arrive de
regarder deux trois revues porno dans
ton cadeau
[Applaudissements]
en parlant de Benjamin Castaldi il y
avait laissé la semaine dernière un jour
votre émission 250 carrière et n'a fait
que les conneries regardez alors
l'émission était enregistrée vendredi
matin mais vous savez Benjamin débutant
le métier du coup il a pas trop encore
les codes de la télé
contrairement aux apparences ah il est
18h43 parce que je vous trouve un peu
pas réveillé ce matin
[Musique]
sur les personnalités dont on parle sur
les dates de naissance qui hésite entre
le prince Harry et et mort aussi hein
il est également le don de ressusciter
les morts et ça c'est pour les plus
jeunes d'entre vous qui nous regardez
dans drôles de dames c'est mon fantasme
absolu de jeunesse je crois qu'elle est
encore pas mal parce qu'il y a eu un
petit montage de Facebook
[Applaudissements]
en imitation Cyril c'est quoi votre
meilleur imitation
[Rires]
aussi lorsque Cyril parle de Gilles
Verdez vous allez voir que c'est pas
pareil
pendant l'antenne regardez Gilles Verdez
la société du laxisme la société du
chaos la société de mes situations
Gilles Verdez
Gilles Verdez la société de la
médiocrité la société
du laxisme
la société
interpellation ultérieure allez on va
écouter Gilles
[Applaudissements]